i'm watching this documentary about  benjamin franklin on apple tv by ken  burns which is amazing yeah i swear to  god swear to god um uh you know  franklin all these inventions that he  made all of them everything he every  invention he's made the the lightning  rod the printing press  didn't patent any of them mad libs  because mad well no mad libs we said was  uh nietzsche  because he didn't believe  in patenting and making money he was  like my inventions are for the world  they're for the people he wouldn't take  any money off his stupid idiot i think  he's a dumb  idiot dumb get paid eating alive on  shark tank yeah mr wonderful is not  investing in him  no he is  he is investing in him he's stealing his  company yeah come on i'll take his  company yeah and benjamin's like i'm i'm  offering this for whatever you think  appropriate  and they're like mr one of was like  i give you a grand for 94 percent